and a little preview for you
by the way they met twice in the regular
season Miami hadn't beaten them nuggets
just the uh uh Obama nugget his Nuggets
won both this year both last year but
won by five and one by four this year uh
the Heat have lost their last six at
Denver yeah well you can go ahead and
put seven eight in game one and two yeah
it sounded like what you said before
this series
hey let me tell you something tell us
something tell us the best team didn't
win
but you say
Miami is not better than Celtics
no no no Hey listen I'll stick by what I
said no the better team did not win this
series
got more Talent you're right you're
right that's the more talented team did
not win this but the better team did uh
if you want to say that but the team had
more Talent than wearing the series now
the difference is going forward with the
Nuggets they're not going to have these
Peaks and valleys
they gonna play they're not gonna come
out there and just jack up threes uh and
just like if we make them we gonna win
I told derney I have not changed any
opinion about the Denver Nuggets I said
when the playoffs started they're going
to win the championship I cannot wait to
get to Denver and
first of all they got they got a really
good break tonight
because the acceptance would have been
now did Jason Tatum injury thing but I
think they it worked out perfect for the
Nuggets it'll definitely be a tall task
for Miami Heat but you know you said
they only won by four or one by five
five
that concerns me you know this is uh you
don't know the situation Jack I could
have been back to back and stuff like
that you just don't know the situation
I don't care if they're so mighty they
would have won by 15 20. so first game
in Denver at the end of December exactly
Joker had triple double uh kcp had 20.
Marie had 14 they shot 59 you talking
like it's gonna be a beat down beat down
here Euro had 26 10 and five hero could
return in this series
um uh from
Chris Haynes uh had a had a uh had this
ramping up workouts expected to make his
return at some point during the finals
with game three being the likely Target
uh League sources tell C Haynes in the
second game in Miami in February Joker
had 27-12 and eight uh Jamal Murray
didn't play they shot 58 percent and won
Butler had 24 10-9 struce 23. that's
just a bunch of numbers I'm throwing it
and that's all going back to February
here we are it's May going into June NBA
Finals again it'll be a tall test with
Miami Heat Joker is the best player in
the league he's playing great Jamal's
playing some inspiring basketball but
the bench the Miami Heat the other is
the way they're playing I'm not going to
count them out yeah I
I would say this mismatches everywhere
Vincent looks so good I mean again same
it was very similar maybe even more
because Porter and and Gordon you know
with their size who also creates some
mismatch but obviously Joker the MVP
candidate and MVP the last two years and
could have won it easily this year you
have Mari playing like an All-Star
easily you would say oh they have
mismatches all the way but
there's only there's only what happens
in basketball there's only a certain
amount of possessions
you know and so it's not like a football
where you could you could dominate the
clock with the amount of possession you
have to shoot the ball in 24 seconds
here so everyone has the same amount of
possessions if you don't turn the
basketball over so if Miami Heat doesn't
turn the basketball over and they play
the way they inspired their way they
that's what beat the Boston Celtics can
they do that with
the devil nuggets visually you go no but
the way they have played this playoffs
I would not count them out here's
another a nugget for you okay the last
time Miami won at Denver
November 30th 2016. 106 98. Joker and
Jamal Murray both coming off the bench
that's hilarious hey man the Denver
Nuggets are a complete team yes they are
they got
I don't get into the matter who the best
player in the world is because you know
Giannis is in that conversation mb1 MVP
Joker has been the best player in the
playoffs Caleb Martin Kayla Martin joke
has been the best player in the MV uh in
the NBA Playoffs so far
I will tell you this
um Miami they play hard they play smart
they got a great coach but I do not see
anybody beating the demo nuggets
all right